aquí tenemos dibujos de cerdos corriendo
y podemos intentar saber cuántos cerdos
corriendo hay si los contamos uno por
uno pero esta vez vamos a empezar a
desarrollar algunos nuevos músculos y
estos músculos van a involucrar la
siguiente idea oye nos ayudaría a saber
cuántos cerdos hay si los agrupamos en
grupos iguales y puedes ver que tenemos
algunos grupos de siete cerditos cada
uno de estos grupos tiene siete cerdos
corriendo así que cuántos grupos iguales
tengo bueno tengo uno dos tres grupos de
siete cerdos corriendo cada uno tres
grupos iguales entonces si digo cuál es
el número total de cerdos corredores con
los que estamos trabajando bueno la
respuesta es tres veces siete
en grupos de siete tres veces siete que
es lo mismo que 777 y si quieres saber
cuánto es esto puedes contar salteado de
siete en siete empezamos el 7 después 14
y 21 entonces tres veces siete es lo
mismo que 7 7 7 que es 21 entonces hay
21 cerdos corriendo y puedes verificarlo
por tu cuenta contando los cerditos si
las cuentas verás que si hay 21 cerdos
hagamos otro ejemplo aquí tenemos el
dibujo de un montón de focas azules y
esto no es algo que comúnmente veas en
la naturaleza y una vez más estas focas
azules han sido agrupadas así que veamos
cuántos grupos tenemos tenemos 1
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete grupos
y cuántas focas hay en cada grupo bueno
puedes ver que tenemos grupos iguales de
uno dos tres cuatro cinco focas azules
son grupos iguales así que cuántas
tenemos en total bueno tenemos siete
grupos de cinco tenemos siete grupos de
cinco o podemos escribir siete veces
cinco siete veces cinco o podemos
escribir cinco más cinco más cinco más 5
555 aquí
hay siete veces cinco ahora podemos
contar salteado ir contando de cinco en
cinco siete veces así que tenemos 5 10
15 20 25 30 35
si sumamos todos estos cincos
obtendremos que 55 es 10 10 + 5 es 15
más otros 5 nos da 20 más otros 5 nos da
25 y otros 5 30 y por último otros 5 nos
dan 35 exactamente lo que tenemos arriba
entonces podemos empezar a ver que
algunas veces agrupar cosas nos puede
ayudar a saber cuántas cosas tenemos y
yo sé que algunos de ustedes está
pensando hoy no puedo simplemente contar
las cosas bueno podrías pero qué pasa si
tienes cientos de grupos de cinco pues
eso te llevaría un poco más de tiempo
para contar
pero las técnicas que estamos
construyendo te ayudarán a que un día
puedas pensar en estas cosas de una
manera más sencilla